let's bring in Bruce Smith most sacks
all-time hall-of-famer bills
hall-of-famer Bruce thanks for joining
us how are you today
I'm doing good would you have more sex
now or less sex now if you play
absolutely I would I would have a
tremendous amount of more sex you know
they're roughly throwing the ball about
thirty percent more than the balanced
attack then I saw in my era so
consequently that gives you more
opportunities to to get after the
quarterback and I having said that was
with the way we threw the ball and how
explosive offensive unit was and all the
weapons we had Thurman Andre Jim James
Lawson Steve tasks or just just a little
of you it would have provided even more
opportunity so you know back then we
there was a balanced attack when when
when teams tried to to approach playing
against us because they wanted to keep
our office on off of the field so they
would if they would typically go 50%
past 50% right how would you have to
adjust to today's rule it would be
extremely difficult quite frankly a
borderline impossible obviously we are
all cognizant of the 2-step rule but
defensive players are being to ask
something that is physically impossible
to do physics won't allow the body to do
or to contort the way they want us to be
able to pull off of delivering a blow
going full-speed
I think the perfect example of that is
the Matthews out in Allen out of Green
Bay this is very disappointing to the
level that these referees are
throwing the flag and the fact that
they're leaving it in the hands of the
the referee as a judgement call the body
is not able to to stop going full-speed
and contort its body in which you won't
fall on the quarterback that's the
nature of the beast this is a violets
for it yeah I wonder though Bruce it
just feels like the NFL is pulling back
the curtain saying we are protecting the
quarterback at all costs they're the
priority we're gonna govern everybody
else by a different set of rules than
the quarterbacks if they came out and
said that would you at least be okay at
least we know you're being transparent
because this man is hard to enforce yes
and Dan they've been saying that for
decades I love the game I love the sport
it's it's a great source of
entertainment but then you get into
these these situations in which they
want to implement a rule that pretty
much saying all the other players are
expendable but this is the one player
that we are going to make sure that we
look after and I just think it's going
to call it's going to cause more
problems in the long run that it will
with the short-term fix of of trying to
implement language that will protect the
quarterback meanwhile it's going to hurt
the opposing team if you look at some of
the hits that were delivered and some
key moments you have to let that
quarterback know that he's going to
throw the ball when he throws the ball
he's going to be under duress and he is
going to be hit and and again this is a
violent sport this is not flat football
this is not touch and for to sit back
and watch the game and see the flag
strong right now I think that the late
great Deacon Jones with which corn the
term sack would be turning over right
now
it's his resting place okay would you
ever think in a million years as a
former defensive great that you would
hear what Gerald McCoy said he was in
the process of hitting Ben
Roethlisberger last night and this is
what he said while he's getting ready to
tackle Ben Roethlisberger my fault Ben
did you ever apologize to a quarterback
Bruce I would I would certainly help
that quarterback up I think that I made
it a routine habit to help up Dan Marino
even John Elway and and a number of
others and that's just showing good
sportsmanship but but meanwhile letting
them know this won't be the last time
that we we will be having this
conversation but but it is it is very
disappointing and it should cause some
alarms and some alert to alerts to the
league that they're gonna have to do
something about this rule
I understand it's an interpretation it's
how the referee sees it in real time at
that moment but to stop a defender from
running full-speed contort his body make
sure that when he drives through that
that quarterback he can't land on that
particular quarterback when the play is
over that just doesn't work that way if
you didn't have the Alzheimer act like
you got ended up with 200 which is a
great number if you had 199 would you
still retire well you know I gotta thank
Dan Snyder for providing the opportunity
for me to extend my my career and we
thought in real time what was putting
together a dream team when we
we were able to acquire a Dion and we
had Champ Bailey and Chris Samuels on
office and Darryl Greene was still
playing and still playing pretty well
but to answer your question I don't know
I I always said that if one of these
three things happened that I would have
to walk away from the game I said if we
weren't winning if I wasn't having any
fun anymore and it's my body just
couldn't take the physical day-to-day
grind a plane that's for it and I said
if one of those occurred during the
course it might be end of my career I
would have to walk away from the game
well it they all happened at the same
time and that was it that was the
determining factor for me I remember
playing my my last year and in with the
Redskins and and I just remember
sometimes it would I would have to miss
the whole week of practice and not be
able to go out and do anything until
Friday because my knees worse were so
swollen and and and the rest of my body
was so banged up and I had smart coaches
that understood that once I walked out
on field I would be ready but I think
that not being able to practice is doing
a disservice to the team
although I was mentally prepared but I
just feel that you need that full
experience of week a week of preparation
studying film lifting weights and and
some types of condition conditioning and
practice who was make sure you're able
to go out and perform at a high level
always the toughest quarterback to bring
down
oh you know they Dan Marino probably was
the toughest he wasn't the most mobile
he couldn't get too hot but that's the
whole point he had such a quick release
and he had he had a success he had eyes
enough the the back of his head that he
felt the pressure coming and he was able
to step to the side and avoid that that
potential knockout blow which would have
which would have been this act but
that's why I always appreciate a plain
against dan dan was was the best in the
business
Dan and obviously there's there's a few
others and just having that that
instinct that separated him from the
average or the the good quarterbacks in
the league is is one of the things that
really excited me about playing this at
office it's good to visit with you again
Bruce thanks for joining us we always
appreciate the opinions and hope you're
doing well
I appreciate it Dan talk to you soon
that's not Bruce Smith for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]